if I asked you to name a microbe that's
living in your gut many of you would
probably say e coli a lot of people say
this it's the best known of the gut
microbes but it turns out that a coli is
outnumbered in your gut about a thousand
to one by other species many of which
you probably haven't heard of these are
Bacteroides private Ella's another
example those are the two that dominate
the modern human gut there are about a
hundred trillion microbes living inside
you we call this your microbiome so it's
like a little world living inside you
actually more like a universe 100
trillion means if you took a blade of
grass and planted it for every microbe
living in your gut that could fill a
million football fields so it's
incredibly complex but interestingly as
our bodies have been adapting to life in
modern society we're losing some of our
normal microbes and at the same time
there are quite a few diseases related
to the gut that are skyrocketing in
developed nations all around the world
and many of you probably know someone
who suffers from obesity diabetes
Crohn's disease are all sort of colitis
allergies and asthma every one of these
diseases and many others related to
metabolism and autoimmunity are linked
to a loss of healthy diversity in the
gut
my lab got our first indication of this
when actually we were studying non-human
primates we wanted to find out what
happens to a monkey's microbiome when
they move from the jungle to a zoo
does their microbiome change do they
pick up new bugs do they lose some does
it get better or worse
we tracked two different species in the
jungle and one in Vietnam one in Costa
Rica and then we sequenced the DNA from
their stool this is how we study the
microbiome in my research lab and what
we found in the DNA is that in the wild
these two species had totally different
sets of microbes it was like a
fingerprint for the species but in the
zoo they had lost most of that diversity
and had acquired some other set of
microbes and so this was very curious
we've got these two different micro
biomes in the wild picture a lush
tropical rainforest living in the guts
of these monkeys that's the kind of
diversity that we're talking about then
in the zoo they've lost diversity
picture rainforests that's been burnt to
the ground and taken over by a few
invasive species that's more like the
microbiome and a captive primate now in
the meantime many of the animals in the
zoo were not doing so well they have
issues with obesity wasting
gastroenteritis diarrhea bloating and
some of them were barely holding onto
their lives now of course we were very
interested to find out what are these
so-called invasive species that are
taking over in the zoo so we went back
to the DNA and what the DNA told us is
that every monkey in the zoo had become
dominated by Bacteroides and private
Ella the same microbes that we all have
in our guts as modern humans we wanted
to find a way to visualize this and we
use some tools from multivariate ecology
to put all of the micro biomes we were
studying onto an axis and what you're
seeing here is a distance plot where
every point is a different animals
microbiome so every point represents a
whole zoo of microbes and the micro
biomes that have a lot of microbes in
common are close to each other the ones
that are very different are farther
apart so this is showing you that the
two groups of wild monkeys are over on
the left the top left are the these
highly endangered monkeys called the red
shanked Duke in Vietnam and in the
bottom left are monkeys from Costa Rica
so you can see that they have totally
different micro biomes in the wild and
then the same two species of monkey in
the zoo are converging so their
microbiomes change and they become much
more similar to each other even though
these are zoos on different continents
different geographical regions they're
eating different diets now we did study
some other species of primate what
species of primate do you think is even
more divergent from the wild primates
than the captive primates modern humans
these are humans living in developing
nations so they were more different from
the wild primates than those in the zoo
and the final group that we studied all
the way on the right is people living in
the USA and when I saw this figure the
hairs raised up on the back of my neck
because one way to think about it is oh
that's interesting captive monkeys are
sort of on their way to becoming like
Americans but the other way to think
about it is that Americans are like
super captive monkeys and I was I was
actually looking at this figure on my
computer screen when I got the news that
four of the red shanked Dukes had died
in the zoo of got related issues so for
some of these animals having the right
microbes living inside them may be a
matter of survival now this brings us to
the human part of the story
obviously the micro biomes in the USA
aren't aren't causing death premature
death as frequently as in the zoo but we
have major risk of obesity
a number of these other diseases and
this applies not just to people who have
been living in the USA for many
generations but also to immigrants and
refugees who for most immigrant and
Refugee groups they arrived in the USA
metabolically healthy and then within a
few years they become just as high risk
for obesity and diabetes as other
Americans and we discussed this issue
with two groups that have been coming to
the USA from Southeast Asia the Hmong
who started coming in the mid-1970s as
refugees from the Vietnam War and the
u.s. secret war in Laos and the Curan
who have been coming more recently as
refugees from Myanmar so we've been
working for a few years with these local
communities and clinicians to study what
happens to the hmong and quran
microbiomes
when people move from refugee camps and
villages in Thailand to the USA and what
we found is that when people come to the
USA from these groups they lose a large
fraction of their microbiome somewhere
around 20 percent and those who come to
the USA and become obese lose about a
third of their microbes so we know that
moving to the USA is sufficient to cause
a dramatic change in your microbiome
probably not for the better
are these microbes actually causing the
obesity or is the obesity causing a
change in the microbes this is something
that we're following up on and the
evidence we have now in my lab combined
with evidence from a number of labs
around the world tells us that certain
changes in the microbiome do lead to
obesity and a number of other modern
kind of westernized diseases the good
news is that your microbiome can
actually change unlike your own genome
it's a living breathing thing and
there's a
front of research right now happening to
better understand how we can restore our
microbiomes when something goes wrong
using diet using live microbes and in
fact one of the next steps for us is
collecting and preserving microbes from
healthy people around the world so that
they can be kept as cultural assets for
those groups to potentially protect them
as they adapt to modern society and to
protect future generations who are you
know currently growing up to have
increased risk of these diseases with
every generation I'm looking forward to
a future where we have the tools that we
need to restore and replenish our micro
biomes and in that world the monkeys
will live path happier and healthier
lives and so will we
[Applause]
[Music]